hi i'm maria i'm a tasty producer today
as always i've been challenged to take a
common food and make it fancy let's see
what we are making fancy today drum
rolls
chicken noodle soup as you can guess
i've never tried this before andy waffle
designed one of his artwork based on
this it's very cool packaging i love
soup in general but i don't
eat candy soup i think in the states you
guys eat when you guys are sick right
so here it's chicken
bunch of like noodles
[Music]
it's not bad just a very bland flavor
color is very yellow and very chickeny
so i think it's very
challenging because we have bloss we
have noodles we have chicken we have
three ingredients and i have to use
everything i'm not quite sure what i'm
going to do i'm still excited to make it
fancy
[Music]
all right
here's what i got ground pork scallions
ginger garlic shitake mushroom toasted
sesame seeds napa cabbage and gelatin
powder from the pantry i got bread flour
cake flour cornstarch sugar salt rice
vinegar soy sauce sesame oil and
magnum side sake it's back okay let's
get started
make it fancy
so first i will need one teaspoon of
gelatin one tablespoon of water and i'm
going to sprinkle we call it bloom the
gelatin it's basically activating
gelatine wait for five to ten minutes
set this aside open this can
chicken soup
if you are sick i don't think you can
open this cat
that's why your mother
can somebody open
help me mom
thank you
i want to separate soup and noodles and
chicken so i'm going to strain this
instruction said add a cup of water it's
a little bit condensed and i'm going to
need two sides of the cup of mixture
adding
chicken soup one tablespoon of soy sauce
it's heating up so add bloomed gelatin
make sure it dissolved well simmer it
for two to three minutes gelatin is
dissolved and soup is boiling whisk it
and transfer to a bowl so you want to
cool this to room temperature and you
are going to put in the refrigerator
about one hour until it sets so next
step separate noodles and the chicken
there is not many chicken pea seeds i'm
gonna just pick it i'm going to use this
with another ingredient one cup of
cornstarch and you kind of want to call
each piece of noodle with cornstarch so
use your gloves or use your tongue if
you don't mind your hands get dirty just
use your hand put in a strainer going to
take small amount and shake it off i
have frying oil heated up to 350. so you
want to fry this until it's golden brown
three to five minutes
i like the sound like
so as you can see when bubbles
start coming down it's almost done but i
think visual cue is the color when
you're frying stuff in japan we say
kitsunedo for golden brown color for
cooking kitsune means fox when it gets
like nice foxy color take this off
you want to season fry the food when
it's still hot so salt kind of melts i'm
going to fry rest of the noodles in
budgets and move on to next step i need
100 grams of bread flour and 25 gram
cake flour half teaspoon of sugar half
teaspoon of salt whisk and i have 1 3
cup of hot water so once it comes
together use my hand and start kneading
once it's like come together it's going
to be smooth and like a baby butt
sprinkle a little bit of cake flour on
the surface gonna knead
it's nice
and bouncy put this in a bowl cover with
plastic and rest this for 30 minutes i
have four scallions
chop
save a little bit for topping later rest
of it combined with pork we have five
ounces of pork
all right it's two months
i told you
we have full ear i don't get there don't
give me any pressure two shiitake
mushrooms remove the stem make it super
fine out in the bowl
you can use patty knife to peel the
ginger about ginger the skin super soft
so you can use spoon so maybe this is an
easy task if you have kids at home and
if you're cooking together wait for your
kids and if you're cooking with your mom
great ginger you don't need to be too
precise but i will need about one
teaspoon of ginger
kind of mask
like porky flavor if you don't have
microplane you can just chop finely and
garlic i'm using two cloves of garlic so
one teaspoon of sake one teaspoon of soy
sauce one teaspoon of sesame oil half
teaspoon of salt combine a little bit
those are the chicken we saved from the
noodle there's only six piece but if
you're sick you don't want to eat
anything chunky maybe it's a good thing
make it mix well and nice i feel like
chicken disappeared somewhere cover this
with plastic put in a refrigerator and
i'm going to use it later the dough is
rested and nice and rustic soft like a
baby bat sprinkle some cake flour
roll out to a long log and cut
into two
cut into five and i have meat fillings
and super jelly i'm going to roll out
and assemble as i go
you should roll the dough and fill as
you go half tablespoon of this filling
don't overfill because it's going to be
difficult to
make the shape pick one side
fold
fold and keep folding
it's kind of like drapes
and once you finish you just pinch the
top part
level of love i'm not pro
of making dumpling but if you go to like
dim sum restaurant there's a people who
is really good at doing it and this is
baby one it's much smaller if you are
doing by yourself it's a little too much
but if you have like two or three
friends making together one person is
rolling one person is feeling one person
is you know shaping and it's gonna be
really fun winter activity i think it's
not perfect but i think it's really cute
i'm going to finish the rest of this and
i'm going to move on to next step so we
have napa cabbage bracket
this is going to be like a natural
parchment paper and we are layering napa
leaf
into a bamboo steamer if you don't have
bamboo steamer you can just use regular
steamer rare
the dumpling you don't want to
make it too close together because it
will stick together but it doesn't
expand so just like make enough room
each other
gelatin will melt in certain
temperatures so it's going to become
just a soup close the basket put on top
of the pot you want to use the paw a
little bit smaller than the basket so it
kind of settles well the steam it is
about 10 to 12 minutes and meanwhile i'm
going to do something else i have more
ginger and i'm going to peel really
quick three tablespoons of soy sauce one
tablespoon of rice vinegar per
ginger
and this is going to be the dipping
sauce so this is the fried noodle we
made earlier
still crunchy and nice it's already
seasoned with salt put it in a bowl
toasted sesame
and the scallion i kind of saved so this
can be a fun appetizer or snacks and i'm
gonna just put on a plate
and i'm done
[Music]
and it's very nice and very fancy
[Music]
welcome andrew for another makeup fancy
episode thank you for having me back
even though i'll never do the dance
dumplings yes i see we have another bowl
of stuff over here i'm not sure what
this is do you want to eat this first
it's appetizer it's a snack
is it a fried noodle yes dip yeah one
bite maybe
[Laughter]
it's good yay that soup bursted in your
mouth it did burst my mouth it was quite
hot is the soup the thing you made fancy
it's not just a soup oh noodle soup yes
chicken chicken noodle soup oh you
chicken noodle soup wow this might be my
favorite one you've done yet you're like
andy warhol
yes i would never have thought to do
this do you feel like doing dance now
since you were so improved i don't even
remember because i've never done make it
fancy make it fancy
it's the best dance you've ever done
it's like a harry potter spell welcome
alia thank you for having me again you
look a little bit different today yes
i've got my piercing going on a while
ago i i did a video where i got piercing
do you like it
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh wow i love
dumplings yes i love dumplings i love
dim sum just go for it
mmm it's cool right it's very good yeah
i think you can go like one bite i think
i'm gonna one bite baby it's a little
big sorry maybe not
sorry
wow
every time this is the best thing you
made me
yes
this is something american people eat
when they're sick like chicken noodle
soup yes chicken noodle soup
that is so impressive
i don't know i don't know how you do it
i don't know how she does it kill you
someday
make it fancy
[Music]